non ce rapport d'étape les cours
soulignent que le plan global de
sécurité doit impérativement être arrêté
pour entrer dans une phase
d'organisation opérationnelle des moyens
si par site sous l'autorité des préfets
par ailleurs le risque capacité que
j’évoquais il y a une seconde reste à
relever notamment on regarde de la scène
d'ouverture qui se déroulera sur la
scène improbable renfort pour partie de
force de sécurité intérieure pour
exécuter des missions relevant
l'organisateur compte tenu du déficit
que j'évoquais probable de force de
sécurité privée doit être anticipée
j'ajoute que son financement doit être
assuré par le kojob il n'y a pas de
raison qu'il repose sur le contribuable
n'oublions pas que les forces font face
par ailleurs à un défi d'équipe
d'émission il y aura les missions liées
au jeu mais il y aura aussi la
permanence des mesures de sécurité sur
l'ensemble du territoire il s'agit pas
de se en quelque sorte et donc l'enjeu
de la série d'ouverture et
particulièrement central on sait qu'un
choix a été fait un choix politique la
cour non dit rien ce n'est pas légitime
pour le faire il reste encore
différentes options possibles la marque
de moment où il est fait il faut se
donner les moyens de l'assumer quant à
la bonne gestion des transports et des
plus de personnes là aussi aborder dans
un rapport en juillet 2022 qui suppose
une articulation étroite avec les zones
de sécurité car ce sont les deux phases
du même pièce il s'agit là d'une
condition sinequanone de la bonne
réussite des jeux à Paris mais aussi en
région or les risques de retard de
livraison de certains projets
structurants renforcent la tension sur
le réseau existant la cour
mais tout particulièrement l'accent sur
l'impératif d'achever à temps les
infrastructures on pense à la ligne 14
ou franchissement urbain Pleyel à la
Porte Maillot ses travaux que nous
connaissons à la gare du Nord on connaît
aussi et d'assurer la disponibilité des
moyens humains et matériels nécessaires
au transport des spectateurs et des
accrédités c'est à dire les sportifs les
médias les délégations internationales
les bénévoles et